inside the Milky Way and every other
galaxy there is a giant black hole at
the center and it's hard to explain
where these came from but even more
peculiar is the fact that at already at
early times there are billion solar mass
black holes that these weigh a billion
times as much as the Sun and this is at
a redshift of six Red chief tells you
how much more dense the universe was at
that time and so you have to in very
rapid fire do something from forming
these foes first pro two stellar objects
collapsing them probably to make in it
before my work people thought you made
relatively small stars and how you're
going to grow those up to making million
and billion solar mass black holes is a
is a puzzle and so one of the
contributions we made was to say hey but
we think that the first stars can be
quite a bit larger and then it would
make sense for the large black holes to
be able to form we think that these
these black holes grow by accretion but
the accretion is in a disk so it's a
it's a flat ring around the black hole
so the stuff is swirling around in the
accretion disk and it's moving pretty
rapidly and in do and before it falls
into the black hole it's giving off
radiation so what you're looking for is
the radiation of this stuff that's
falling into the black hole and from
studying that in addition to what you
are already saying about the motions of
other things around the black hole you
can you can infer that the black hole
should be there
the galaxy is a galaxies and in fact the
universe as a whole have the they're
made of different pieces in the atomic
matter actually is only very small
portion so the the rest being the dark
matter and in fact this is it's kind of
its revolutionary over the past decade
that this has become clear that if you
add up everything that we're familiar
with on a daily basis such as your body
that walls the planets all these things
all that atomic matter only adds up to
four percent of the total content of the
universe and the the other breakdown is
in terms of dark matter and dark energy
and right now we're talking about the
dark matter which is the predominant
bulk of the mass in the in the galaxies
and clusters and so on so when people
study these first stars they were aware
that they form inside these big globes
of dark matter and at the center of this
of the dark matter you have a
protostellar cloud of hydrogen and
helium that's that starts to collapse so
our contribution was to say well but
what about that huge bulk of material
that's out there doesn't it play a role
in in this star formation process
especially because these first stars are
forming smack in the middle of these of
these these spherical regions are called
halos so these halos of dark matter
especially near the Centers is where a
lot there's a huge amount of dark matter
in there and that's where your stars for
me so what we think happens is that the
there is a a kind of dark matter power
basically the dark matter particles and
the ones that we believe there's a lot
of experiments going on right now to try
to detect these particles and I think
that it's going to be resolved in the
next five years ten years at most and
the most likely candidate they're called
wimps which stands for weakly
interacting massive particles so and
these wimps whenever there's two of them
that that find each other they interact
among themselves and they actually
annihilate so they lose their original
identity and
they turn into something else but in
that annihilate that annihilation
process dumps a lot of heat into this
protostellar material so you've got this
protostellar cloud that's trying to
collapse to make a small star but all of
a sudden boom you're stopped because you
have this heat source that stabilizes
the cloud and prevents it from
collapsing anymore so yeah it's actually
really a star that then the nomenclature
Dark Star could be a little misleading
in the sense of people think well it's
probably made of dark matter but it
really isn't it's really made of
hydrogen and helium and just a
smattering of dark matter is it's it's a
very powerful heat source and less than
1% of the masses dark matter and the
annihilation process gives a heat source
that powers the star and it shines very
bright objects they really are stars so
they're their atomic objects that shine
due to the Dark Matter power